new report obtained by CBS s warning  claims that electric carmaker Tesla's  production growth might be coming at the  expense of worker safety the analysis  was conducted by the health and safety  advocacy group called WorkSafe the  report shows in 2015 the number of  recordable injuries at Tesla's factory  in Fremont California was 31% higher  than the industry average the rate of  serious injury injuries rather was about  double the industry rate that year in a  statement Tesla says this we may have  had some challenges in the past but with  changes we now have the lowest injury  rate in the industry by far Carter Evans  spoke with some of the employees making  the accusations what is the chief  complaint here the injuries are the  number one problem there did you ever  tell any managers about this managers  and supervisors and what they do looked  at me as a as a complainer Tehran CBS  this morning more from Carter's  interviewing it look inside the Tesla  factory